this week we've got double robbery Stu
donut mischief what in poop bomb mark
what I haven't smelled this fart well
you've been holding it in for her I fart
in some places yeah he leaves it's where
all the plants are dead before the
garage and I go into the pantry and a
closet the pantry if I'm closer to the
pantry yeah but gets high the first
story this man was accused of robbing
the same Dairy Queen twice and two hours
DQ yo you robbed a Dairy Queen even go
to hell there's not many DQ's around
anymore especially in our area this
happened in Colorado do y'all remember
Orange Julius yeah the original Jamba
Juice oh yeah they doing like malls and
stuff next to like the hottest Main
Street I don't know where but they had
these potatoes that were really good and
then the orange drink was so good hate
us to have potatoes they're just
potatoes it was like wedged potatoes my
taters I remembered there was an Orange
Julius next to a Chipotle and I would
get a burrito from Chipotle they get a
big orange juice I don't know they
existed in the same era cuz it was there
before the Jabba juice was and I used to
get that and then I saw that the the
Orange Julius drink had like 1500
calories in it
Oh God anyways that I knew I took the
knowledge and I was like well I
shouldn't eat this but I still ate it
tastes like a creamsicle well maybe
these do ice cream it's probably just
creamsicle melted swirled around serve
but they always had that flowing orange
thing no the one I was thinking about is
a different juice thing but yeah you
think about orange Greg how you mess
again
speaking about robic oh oh oh oh
you think of a hot is bang always at
Topshop you got the horchata machine the
orange oh my god I pictured Tang in my
mind hey only poor Mexicans drink that
stuff
hey I [ __ ] like drinking a lot we
still have taken our house what I think
wanted to taste it poor Mexican but you
could only buy that in an 18 gallon
because when we had this huge tub
Department I did I used to also eat
those little pinwheels with the type of
teal and the [ __ ] life oh I don't
know don't add up skin I thought it was
a flea market thing actually pretty much
ah that makes please our Mexican theme
whoa whoa whoa you got a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right next to you bro yeah corrector I'm
Mexican yes a Mexican a Spaniard flea
the correct term is the unemployed no
the unregistered stupid is sex again and
that you want to not have sex again I'm
trying to get you riled up yeah you
start to get you out your [ __ ]
feathers all rustled up yeah gets me
extra [ __ ] he's doing roleplay well
you don't have your green card and
you're trying to run away he's let me go
and then you [ __ ] him run away run baby
I'm coming see anyone before the phone
and he was there both were born here you
said you were I lied I was important I
was born for you yeah I was born talent
we need you come you know when I was
like six eight months old we were born
here and documented pieces of [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you me let me go yeah but it's
it's worse than you were born here and
your English sucked before you met us
that's ten times worse that's true
when I came to I could even speak
English [ __ ] man be but you know what
with her limited English she's still in
the same run stupid ass thank you but in
your [ __ ] face
I didn't all right you came up on me
right there huh that's my girl you guys
should do stereotypical roleplay where
Bart jumps out of a container and then
you hop over the fence and you guys mean
but I was born here I'm more Asian than
him I was born in Monterey Park oh you
were yeah which side of the freeway
Monterey Park Hospital so six the south
of this sick all right
shot one of six you know we did north
okay south of the 60th not china bruh
yeah like that's Mexico Monterey Park
Hospital where Street is that I'm gonna
make it closer to home
all right Bart's cooking at the Chinese
restaurant and Gio is chopping
vegetables in the back and then y'all
[ __ ] in the kitchen see that's that's
stereotypical role play right okay yeah
then you don't wash your hands after you
make yep the hospitals north to the
fruit but Joe ass was living south that
it wasn't you yeah she was sure I was in
East LA so she's still Mexican I did
that the first story so this man
remember he robbed the same dairy clean
up ice in one day yeah that guy yes so
guys a gambler he first robbed Dairy
Queen around 9:00 p.m. and so the cops
responded to that because it was an
armed robbery so he did get away with an
undetermined amount of cash but before
he fled he was trying to carjack a
customer at the drive-thru but he failed
he failed that so he had to leave on
foot okay and then less than two hours
later around 10:40 p.m. that's when he
returned because it wasn't enough and he
robbed it again dude are the employees
like are you [ __ ] kidding me a guy
he's so pants too I'm like also
attempted again to carjack someone
from the drive same guy cuz he forgot
something - oh no sorry it wasn't the
drive through the second time it was
just like he tried to steal the car and
it was a Dairy Queen employees car but
we couldn't get it
dang his PC [ __ ] twice his self-esteem
must be really low dude no it's like win
lost win loss he like God you know yeah
but every time he tries to Jack a car
nobody takes him seriously his
self-esteem must be shot right now
it's a Dairy Queen if I like he's like
robbing a bank I mean but if somebody
put a gun in my face in my card they get
out the car I probably got out the car
I'll get out but he's so unassuming they
go get out the car they go get [ __ ] out
here if someone was outside and you guys
would get out the car cuz you could hit
the gas and drive away I'm gonna just
take a hot it depends they're not gonna
shoot your car I saw all that never
happens
I saw a video recently of a cop that was
telling - dude together of his car and
he said no and the guy just started
rolling his car a little bit in the car
blasted like a bullet oh my god ever
seen that [ __ ] before and then it was
terrible because the gap when the cop
was shooting and he unloaded on him and
then he got in front of the car and got
on the hood to make it seem like he was
trying to run him over gotta top again
it was so bad dude yeah now I'm scared
all right so this is levee man what the
[ __ ] whoa-ho oh he looks like a
celebrity like he could be a celebrity
nah [ __ ] that Matthew McConaughey yeah
or something huh
this fool took a picture in a tornado
brain is like showing through his
forehead he's got a 5 head that looks
like a little bit like Charles Manson
forehead didn't face almost yeah that
one looks like Charles Manson a little
bit like Tyrion Lannister oh yeah a
little bit
wait where was this at Colorado rise
what happened to like we're gonna take a
picture and then he goes oh really
No yeah - he looks like he does magic
and meth yeah so the cops were able
since like they were nearby already they
took out their night vision equipment
and they went looking for him and he was
found in a Prairie in the Prairie yeah
is it a prairie like a field yeah
frolicking like though [ __ ] I wonder
what he Jack - well he got away with
somethin he didn't get any ice cream I
would at least told him the [ __ ]
making some ice cream [ __ ] this full
with the Dairy Queen beans and ice cream
give me all your money in a Sunday make
it quick
trying to run dumb if you were smart
dudes like you want you on that sauce
today
sure yeah kind of get more fudge you to
rob the soft-serve machines because
those are worth a lot of money
how's it gonna carry bring those dollies
no wonder you're not a [ __ ] checker
wait a jacker huh no wonder you're that
jacker see that's why they say don't
judge a book by it's cover but I'm
[ __ ] judging man that [ __ ]
looks like he does every crime on
criminal this woman she was arrested
after shattering a door at a coffee shop
because the business did not have any
donuts she showed us what she showed up
around 4:15 a.m. oh [ __ ] she became
enraged because there were no donuts at
4:00 a.m. I'm on her side and so she
shouted at the staff left yes our coffee
shop they say is it a Vietnamese donut
shop Cambodia me oh well I don't know
cuz we always go to Vietnamese where do
we what's the place called where we go
and they never have anything ready cuz
they open up at 9:00 leave yeah but then
they don't have anything cooked or baked
or anything cuz it looks like they open
up and they're like are ya you're
suppose that before you open up yeah
haha yeah that's my cousin spot yeah
really yeah your cousin [ __ ] sucks
yeah oh wait it's not actually my cousin
racist just a baguette yeah yeah so then
she left the coffee shop and so when she
exited the door she kicked open the
glass door causing it to shatter and
this she fled oh yeah that's what
happened it was an actual rage like it
actually broke yeah this happened on
April 22nd on May 2nd
around 5:30 a.m. she came back she came
back so the employees called the cops
and said like a this [ __ ] is back so
maybe cuz she just really liked the
doughnuts there and she's like she's
like mango remember me has been at least
two weeks yeah so she they the only
describe her as a 30 year old woman she
was arrested and charged with mischief
under $5,000 all right I understand if
at 6 p.m. there's no certain Donuts
because you know donuts are made at 3
a.m. or earlier or midnight it's
supposed to be ready by 4:00 a.m. yeah
you're right by the time I [ __ ] go
there to pick up a donut with my coffee
before I get to work I think if it's a
donut shop sure I think it was a coffee
shop yeah but if they always talking
about Donuts right now but if they
always have Donuts if they always have
guarantee
I expect my [ __ ] donut okay fair
enough I don't care if it's a coffee
shop or a fabulous sandwich shop if
there's doughnuts always there cuz you
only need to go once to have really
shitty service and you're not gonna go
back since she went back that's dumb
that's why I bet you she'd they have
really good doughnuts that's the thing
she has really strong feet or it's just
the closest spots in her apartment or
she has really strong meth this had been
in in Canada by the way it never
happened to what she should have got a
Tim Hortons man the [ __ ] we all defend
the Canadians right away
actually Canadian or she like you know
does happen in Kingston Kingston Ontario
Jimmy I don't know what that's that okay
moving on to our last story this man
used dog poop to make a bomb that makes
sense
yep I get it how do you do that well I
got a lot of [ __ ] if he wants to teach
me so but are you gonna just giving it
to him
we like literal bomb it's not like a
conceptual like us like a stink bomb
where it's just like it's so smelly it's
like a little bomb like something
exploded so what he did is he had this
toolbox that contained a battery wiring
switches and an air bag from a car and
so you took it over to his former
friends home oh so he called him saying
hey I left the toolbox in the back of a
Camaro and so when he opened it it
exploded with such a force that it
sounded like an m-80 going off and dog
[ __ ] was blown out of the bottle oh it's
that kind of dog [ __ ] bomb the dogs just
shrapnel so it's a regular bomb that has
dog [ __ ] around yeah cuz I thought he
made it through with dog [ __ ] like like
you know they do it with fertilizer and
[ __ ] yeah yeah so he's saying that he
collected the dog feces from his his dog
and other dogs that defecate around his
courtyard what a piece of loser like the
shed yeah you know what I understand the
frustration though I understand when
people don't pick up their dog [ __ ] and
they [ __ ] all over your [ __ ] lawn oh
yeah you have to pick it up consistently
yeah pisses me but that's not why he did
it he did it for his ex friend not cuz
he was mad at the dog [ __ ] I thought he
was all you fill in that blank all I was
doing it from my own justice yeah yeah
yeah you know what though I'm with I
understand why he did this because I can
tell you why he did it he did it because
he was angry at his former friend for
failing to return something of his
library book favorite porn collection or
[ __ ] oh we're back if he's your friend
so you they were also saying that one of
the things that they both really and
like to do together was to watch youtube
videos of people pulling pranks
the reason why he came up with this idea
fair enough oh so was it like a
vengeance thing uh well they are saying
that that's pretty hardcore though the
friend doesn't seem to be hurt because
the court papers don't describe any
injuries there's just Dookie between his
teeth and also the guy wasn't charged
with it with assault so it I don't see
mother pretty cool yeah but he did get
booked into jail and he was released
after posting at $2,000 per bond that
same day date two thousand dollars
that's a regretful bomb he was like I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to blow dog
[ __ ] in some his face and then have to
pay $2,000 and then also they searched
his home they found meth shotgun Oh
leading to more charges of meth
possession being a being a felon in
possession of a foreign I fell in that's
what they're saying they should of a
fart unlock possession of a creative
with the way you know that you're toxic
drug possession no it sounded kind of
like you're like instead of saying a
firearm you're like far far mmm
I can't even see that well because I
think you've got not roots you know [ __ ]
it was born here too and everything huh
okay well you didn't grow up in a
Mexican I did go up it in Mexican bubble
I people told me I sound a Mexican you
did both do you both sound like my
cousin I sound British as [ __ ] no you
don't ask fuck-ass [ __ ] be British for
the rest of this episode I am hello love
yeah so he is this guy makes all sorts
of poor decisions yeah do you want to
see his face yeah of course here you
gonna be the last dude I bet he has a
widow's peak no way a really thick one
oh my name is Rob he's 48 years old and
he's from Portland so what's that
widow's peak right now did I think that
no like oh man no I think he's like the
most normal looking dude we've ever seen
on JK news like he could have done his
hair he doesn't fit the description of
meth you know what I mean yeah yeah he's
like maybe bodyguard for meth
deliver he looks like he feels bad that
he [ __ ] up on the amount of gunpowder
he used I think so I mean aside from the
choice of drug of meth being for white
people's like we don't we don't there's
nothing else that fits the description
they should be put this this logo
doesn't make sense throwing off and
makes it look like he's the sheriff
yeah he just finished the training
academy or something but they don't
argent but that's a little weird over
here he's 40 years old forty-eight just
a refresh that's 37 okay he's almost 10
years younger
yeah a hundred percent that is gonna be
a new Matthew McConaughey movie this
fool looks like a Russia [ __ ] yeah or
Christian Bale plan yeah he looks like a
Russian philosopher that does magic on
the side and meth and all that is
everyone do magic in your magic tricks
are like Magic the Gathering no like no
like a wizard like a real magic like
magic not like fake magic magic not like
that is that the real do you think now I
go red balls and [ __ ] like we're talking
like voodoo stuff yeah magic tricks
magic Merlin magic okay the real ones
got a [ __ ] cauldron yeah how do you
talk to somebody like that with such a
big forehead without staring at it dude
you run if I saw that my spidey senses
are already tingling and then like
people go
you shouldn't [ __ ] judge and be like
this and all that [ __ ] and I'm all like
it's not racism it's just [ __ ] fear
dumb look at the way he looks I know I
can't help but hope he does you know
what I mean you guys have to feel that
sometimes yeah when they're bad people
yeah yeah that's something he looks yeah
but when things look disgusting you want
them to also go away yeah good thing you
don't know him personally I don't know
anybody like that personally the only
crazy people I know and this dude even
mother mother Theresa would look at that
phone be like not you not you looks like
he smells you know I mean it's smelling
[ __ ] mom this will look like he's got a
pimp sperm at the same time he's a
[ __ ] skinhead
it's like how does that even work like
you got like Lego hair that was put on
my
a little sideways so they need to like
read oh he does he looks bald and he
just put a bunch of like hair clippings
on the barbershop yeah do it on his head
when you found that James Brown wig or
something yeah it's like it's like this
though we're actually talking about this
guy right now the other guy just looks
like a creature cuz this guy looks like
he's like man I wish my friend ain't
around on me like Colin Farrell's older
brother this guy looks like a
dishonourable okay look at the other guy
this was a dishonorable night right look
at the other guy that was a medieval
molester molester where did ye but hoga
[Music]